pour en parler nous sommes avec camille
sari économise président de l'institut
euro maghrébin d'étude et de prospective
bonsoir camille sari on l'a vu dans ce
sujet en prochaine réunion de l'opep
jeudi et vendredi à vienne la demande en
pétrole risquent de continuer à abaisser
façon au coronavirus quelles
conséquences selon vous les conséquences
sont dramatiques pour les pays
mono exportateurs comme les pays de
l'opep essentiellement l'arabie saoudite
le veut le qatar il qui exportent
beaucoup de gaz enfin les émirats et
cetera ce sont des économies peu
diversifiée qui ont des problèmes aussi
de 2 d'évolution démographique et de de
budget des forces qui sont très élevés
je prends l'exemple aussi de l'algérie
dans le même cas alors que la russie a
un coût de production inférieurs déjà
par rapport à d'autres pays
ferrures du point de vue de
l'exploitation et c'est une économie qui
qui a toujours été industriel qui a qui
est diversifiée et qui dispose aussi
d'autres matières premières et d'autres
ressources
ceci étant tous les pays sans exception
exportateurs de pétrole
à mon avis moi je les dis à un mois
quand les marchés étaient au plus haut
j'avais alerté sur le fait que les
autorités chinoises ne disent pas la
vérité sur le les victimes réelles le
nombre de victimes réelles et on a vu
comment
les iraniens qui se déplaçait beaucoup
chine ont été contaminées compris des
hauts responsables ils ont les iraniens
qui voyagent dans toute la région et qui
aussi des mini ski qui rentrent plus ou
moins clandestinement en irak ou yamani
en syrie ils ont contaminé toute la
région et le coût pour l'arabie saoudite
c'est l'annulation de du pèlerinage de
la omra peut-être même de le grand
pèlerinage c'est une perte vraiment qui
se chiffrent à plusieurs millions
peut-être même plusieurs milliards
l'essentiel dans cette crise ce n'est
pas tant les victimes qu'il faut
déplorer
chacun d'entre nous pourraient être
concernés haut dans sa famille c'est pas
ça le saas est important mais c'est
aussi les précautions prises parce que
il ya un principe de précaution qui dit
que si un risque il faut annuler telle
ou telle manifestation en france ont
annulé une journée donc du salon de
l'agriculture qui avait attaqué sa queue
et puis on voit dans beaucoup de pays
l'annulation du salon de l'auto model au
jeu genève aux femmes et puis sur règles
milan et 10 millions de pertes
effectivement les et surtout ce qu'il
faut déplorer et ça aussi le marché de
pétroliers stéphanie c'est un marché
spéculatif c'est c'est un débat n'était
pas de confiance et majeurs soient là
cette affaire c'est pas on n'achète pas
et en vaut pas le plus le pétrole pour
le consommer au dos la majeure partie
des cas c'est à dire c'est une matière
que vous vous pouvez achetez moi aussi
je jette
j'achète ça à terme et je revault avec
un bénéfice mais des fois ça peut être
une perte
donc c'est très spéculatif qu'au marché
mais le fond du fossé que l'économie
réelle et c'est ça qui est très
important c'est que ça qui n a pas été
pris en compte par les marchés
financiers les marchés du pétrole et
l'ensemble des acteurs et même des
responsables économiques
c'est que l'économie réelle
et va souffrir elle souffre déjà savez
vous que la chine contrairement à 2003
la chine c'est un occupe 30 % des biens
intermédiaires c'est à dire les produits
semi finis destinés à l'industrie
mondiale des midis cabot les produits
les pièces il ya des iphone qui ne
peuvent plus être fabriquée par ce
qu'ils m'ont ce dps qui verrait veine de
chine
à l'heure actuelle les ports sont à
l'arrêt quasiment en chine
c'est à dire que les bateaux qui sont
partis il ya quelques mois ils sont
arrivés les rayons de se rendre compte
qu'on est trop dépendant de la chine de
changer peut-être ce modèle mais
absolument c'est ce que c'est mon
plaidoyer depuis longtemps et je les
écris parce que la chine j'ai eu la
chance ou l'opportunité de voyager en
chine depuis 1992
j'ai vu comment tout les industriels
américains européens et se sont
précipités aussi pour acheter des
marchandises et pour délocaliser
il n'y avait pas une zone industrielle
que j'ai pas visiter il n'y a pas
d'industrie et ils sont très dépendants
l'allemagne archi dépendantes et
d'autres pays également
et tous ces pays là ils ont délocalisé
maintenant ils sont vraiment coincé
c'est à dire que l'économie mondiale
elle est dépendante actuellement de la
chine de l'inde ou la chine représente
25% du pib mondial
les industries chinoises sont en parc du
sinn du monde savait ce que nizar et
pardonnez moi de vous couper il reste
peu de temps ça veut dire qu'on doit
vraiment selon vous selon l'économiste
que vous êtes s'inquiéter aujourd'hui
clairement des conséquences économiques
de cette crise du lait
j'ai ce problème
depuis amoureux et rapide d'oeil à moi
je suis vraiment drôle dans l'embarras
de dire que ça va être pire que ce que
nous avons actuellement c'est à dire que
ça va il y aura une paralysie des
activités que ce soit en europe ou aux
états unis petit peu plus le le virus il
s'est en plus on va fermer des centres
commerciaux des usines
il ya déjà beaucoup de pme qui ont fermé
des pme que ce soit en europe ou aux
états unis les états unis et les chiens
elle trompe a été critiqué sur la vérité
des chiffres
et puis c'est pas par là par une
injection de liquidités au par une
baisse des taux d'intérêt à deux d'un
demi point que l'économie mondiale va
être relancée il faut revenir à
l'économie réelle par un pessimisme on
se quitte merci camille sari rester avec
nous dans quelques instants